a little more magical because magician
michael carbonaro is bringing his show
to the pen and teller theater at the rio
and he's here with us today to tell us
all about it how are you i'm great thank
you for having me congratulations on the
show i'm sorry i just watched this guy's
youtube videos he is unbelievable that's
awesome thank you thank you you got the
green light from donnie that's when you
know you've made it how about that's a
good first day in vegas and the
interview now you're good
come see the show yeah we're done we're
out of here that's awesome we'll talk
about surprises that's so exciting i
know you're usually doing the surprising
on us when you show us a trick well if
donnie says yes and we're all saying yes
congratulations on this show you were
saying this is like the first time that
penn and teller has welcomed someone
onto their stage yeah they're taking off
to australia for seven weeks and they
just asked they're like hey you want to
do you want to do something in our
theater i was like are you i thought
they were pranking me right
i was like absolutely so yeah i start
thursday doing four shows a week for
seven weeks it's going to be amazing
well obviously donnie mentioned you're
all over tik tok you've had your show
you're always showing us how do you keep
it fresh and think of new ideas and get
creative yeah i just think of things
that i would either fall for or want to
see happen and that i make those things
become real you know i like just picture
myself being out in the audience like if
i was going to see this guy that i saw
on tv pulling pranks what would that
live show look like i would want him
even though i knew that he was a
magician i want him to prank me i want
to really be fooled and that's what i do
and the people you know the energy is
just so exciting you can see a lot of
people who wonder if on tv it's like
camera tricks or actors you see them
like right there being like okay i'm
seeing this happen right in front of my
face this is real yeah you can probably
change the minds of those skepticals
that are out there and i actually
watched the one video on tick tock over
and over again with the delivery truck
guy who opens the envelope and then
there's the photos of him delivering
that package like how did those things
get
lost in a loop of time yes you're always
thinking of something new and fresh and
with this show tell us a little bit do
you get the audience involved or what
can we expect definitely like i'm out
there i borrow objects from them they
come up on the stage and play you know
and it goes
anything from you know there's there's
mischievous gnomes that keep haunting us
throughout the night um i show people
how to magically separate laundry oh and
uh
and then i strip down and cover myself
in shaving cream
and that's not a lie that's that's the
truth well you're giving away all the
secrets now we got it again and still
family friendly and still a family
friendly show that was going to be my
next question so it's you know
acceptable for all ages absolutely yeah
i love that that's my favorite kind of
crowd to perform for and people always
you know they say they watch the
carbonaro effect with their families so
it's like those families now come out to
see the show together and it's just just
a beautiful energy and i always love to
hear the stories about magicians
sometimes there's certain things you
learn or do growing up that you're like
okay i'm to do card tricks or i'm going
to do things what kind of inspired you
to get into this industry i was actually
interested in special makeup effects i
love horror movies and i love that you
know special effects artists are really
magicians yeah so i used to buy a lot of
makeup supplies at a local magic shop
and i started watching them doing magic
behind the counter and i was like i
started picking up some tricks and
trying them so so special effects
brought me to magic magic brought me to
performing i just love
getting to perform live for people and
watching their reactions and relate with
them wow that is something i've never
heard before that's really interesting
i'd love to hear that and i know you
have a trick planned for uh i asked if
you could if i could borrow a dollar
bill okay i just happened to have you
haven't written
in your hands for you you just tricked
me
everybody i asked everyone in the studio
to find one okay good yeah well it's
important it wasn't mine that it was
yours great that's real yes okay so this
is a simple little uh this is a four-way
inter-dimensional time warp oh okay i'm
gonna do here with your bill so i'm
gonna fold it
it's kind of a reverse origami okay and
the word origami backwards is imagino
which is the italian word for
imagination are you making this up
that's a lie yeah
reverse origami is an unfolding process
it's not where you fold something into
something new it's where you unfold it
into something that it couldn't be
do you see how it kind of unfolds you
pull the center out
and the middle to the edges
and you pull the bill can you guys see
that and it's and it's not just a fake
bill taped together you could even
examine it absolutely not
i kind of touch it you actually can oh
my god what
can you guys see i don't know if you can
zoom in on this or not but
everyone in here is saying what what we
got to bring donnie and come over here
[Laughter]
so do you
think i could use that at the grocery
store or is that did you just like
destroy my dollar bill you uh it's
actually a federal offense i'm glad that
wasn't a police officer coming in yes
defacing government property but now
it's your bill so your response this is
my souvenir yes this is so awesome and
i'm sure just one of the many tricks
that you do on stage this is so cool i'm
you know i'm really trying to figure out
how how i'm i'm pulling it and you know
sometimes you're like oh is that a prob
or is that no right we no yeah seriously
got this from someone here on our studio
floor it's amazing paper paper is
pliable in that way okay that's true yes
both ways
michael thank you so much this was so
fun we'll see if we can get my dollar
back together later but for now this is
so cool
all right be sure to go see marco
michael carpenter lies on stage you saw
it here he was lying to me but you know
what i'm still going i'm supporting it
these shows are thursday through sunday
they start at 8pm now through july 10th
at the rio all suite hotel and casino
tickets are available on
ticketmaster.com now let's send it to
ted with a look at your most accurate
weather now